while a lot of the shows on the strip
are still shut down one performance is
about to take to the stage
off the strip it is called ignite and
it's actually collaboration of several
different acrobats and dancers
from a lot of the popular shows you
might have seen in the past and missed
recently
christian casadas got an exclusive
behind-the-scenes peek into the
raw production we say raw because it's
going to actually happen on a ranch
right that's right denise well this show
is called ignite and that's exactly what
it's hoping to do next month
at the outdoor horse arena at sandy at
sandy valley ranch
now think las vegas under the stars
eight news now was invited exclusively
to their first rehearsal
in the southwest about two dozen
performers had to come up
with their own act and they've been
practicing at home because of covet
now the hour and a half two-day show
will highlight
talents from many vegas shows that were
shut down because of the pandemic
and left hundreds of dancers without
work the two creators of the shows have
years of experience working
on multiple cirque du soleil productions
and they hope the community
is just as eager to come out and enjoy
some live entertainment
as they are the theme of the show is
just that
kind of the build up of the the feelings
that we had
from right when we went to shut down of
that fear and that uncertainty and
also some some of us a little bit of
doubt
and then going through the the whole
emotional
process well the show will take place at
sandy valley ranch on may 7th
and on the 8th and social distancing
will be enforced
now before and after the production
people will be able to enjoy the 40-acre
property with a variety of food trucks
music and of course the great sunset of
the mojave desert now tickets are
selling out quickly since it's only a
two-day show
now there is transportation available
and overnight lodging too
all that information is available on our
website eightnewsnow.com christian
casadas 8 news now